hey Mike how are you I'm great Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
I got a scenario for you you know I hear
a lot of success stories you know when
you show people call in and they're due
to give the debt free scream and all
that stuff and that's great wonderful
and I want to get into that position
cool
um but it seems like it's like I don't I
don't understand how to do it like I
don't know like I work off Commission
and my wife doesn't okay well I think I
think what we our w-2s recorded yet last
year were approximately exact figure but
around eighty eighty two thousand as
you're making good money it's just it
just comes and goes and it's not
predictable it makes it very hard to
budget using traditional budget methods
is that what you're saying right yes
because I work because my checks are
never the same yeah yeah um here's what
we did here's what we've learned to do
Sharon and I had to do this when we
first started Mike because I was doing
real estate back then and some months I
literally made zero and then the next I
might make 20 grand the next month you
know so it was all it was really
volatile the good news is you've at
least got the baseline of your wife's
income and you probably never have a
zero month you just have a you just
don't know what it's going to be exactly
right correct okay so here's what we
teach folks to do and this works really
good you do your normal zero based
budget now what that means is you do a
budget that you just lay out your
spending you spend every dollar of your
known income on paper before the month
begins every dollar has an assignment so
what is your wife's take-home pay in a
month in a month she's probably around
twelve thirteen hundred okay and what is
your worst month's take-home pay last
year um you're probably looking about 80
hours times 20 so oh I think the worst
was probably 1200 okay so she made 1200
you made 1200 was your worst month was
$2,400 right right okay right let's run
a budget on 2500
a regular budget okay how much is your
house payment
twelve twelve okay so there's a bunch of
it and they take your lights and water
out take some food out and we're and you
know you know let's do some of the basic
really important things food shelter
clothing transportation and use up that
twenty five hundred right quick okay oh
now there's a bunch of stuff didn't make
that list right oh yeah
okay our payments exactly well I mean
you may get to one of those there but it
depends on what you're spending on food
but I mean if you spend the five hundred
bucks on food you spend more than that
if you spend let's say eight hundred
bucks on food that puts you at two
thousand then you got five hundred more
for lights and water yeah you may not
get that you're not going to get to the
car payments okay so let's make a list
of all the things that the twenty five
hundred did not cover you follow me go
look at that list and say what is the
most important thing on that list that I
have to do with the first dollar that
comes in above twenty-five hundred and
it's probably going to be a car payment
in your situation but a car payment
slash insurance yeah yeah well car
payment you pay before you pay insurance
you pay insurance right after that
they're both important but you know
you're probably not going to have
another $1,200 a month you aren't you're
probably but so we're shooting low but
we're going to make a list and you look
at that list use okay if I can only do
one bill above the $2,500 budget that
didn't make the list you follow my
thinking what would I do and you put a
number one beside that now let's pretend
that one's paid if I can do one more
what would I do and you put a two beside
that if I can do one more what would I
do and you put a three beside that if I
can do one more pretty soon you're going
to get all the basics covered and you're
going to be down into knocking out basic
bills then you're going to get on to
where you say if I could do one more
what I do I'd save some money or I would
I would work my debt snowball or
wherever you were in the baby steps but
those things don't happen until you get
your basics covered you follow me well
so you then take that list where you've
numbered everything by priority you
rewrite the list in priority and that's
called an irregular income planning
sheet
so your first 2500 spent so your wife's
checks spent and your first twelve or
fourteen hundred that comes in and spent
right that's gone then in the first
check you get that breaks through that
plane breaks through the top of that
twenty five hundred dollar amount is
going to go to number one you follow me
yeah and you don't do anything else
until number one is done as soon as it's
done you got any more money you go to
number two soon as that's done you go to
number three and what we learn to do was
we went on over on the right hand column
of that prioritized sheet and we ran a
running total
in other words number one plus number
two equals plus number 3 equals plus
number four equals so the first four
added up or $712 or whatever they are I
just made that number up okay then if
you get a check in for seven hundred
bucks you go well look at that I can
knock out I'm done with my baseline my
twenty five hundred and I can knock out
number one through four and you draw
lines through those you pay those bills
and then the next check that comes in
you pick up you pay number five through
whatever and you rewrite that list a
couple times usually during the month so
you can just keep up with where you are
but you don't spend money anywhere that
you haven't written down and if you have
oh sorry oh I haven't brought up I
haven't brought up this point what now
um and it gets a little bit more
difficult when you hear here what's
going on I spoke to the screener about
this okay
um like this past weekend yeah we had no
food we had nothing um we had twelve
dollars in our bank account no because
you didn't have a plan i well yeah
that's then but what do I do now I mean
do what I would I go you plan for the
next week when's your next check about
you understand we're we're almost
negative every pay period well no no no
you're not negative until you spent the
money
oh no it's negative the bank accounts in
red okay every month it's like this no
because you're spending money listen if
you light out a plan for your next check
you would never lay out a plan to take
you into the negative you follow me and
so I guess I don't I don't get so when
is your next check coming um I I get
paid on the fifth and twentieth okay
so you get a check in a couple days
when it's our next check coming purged
that comes with this Wednesday but we're
negative so we're all ready okay all
right well that there we go so stop a
second how much is our always in the
hole okay so how much is her check
twelve hundred six hundred bucks right
yeah it's okay so we're going to we're
going to go and spend her check right
now on paper
two hundred of it's gone we got to get
positive okay you spend the next four
hundred what two hundred for a mattock
withdrawal yep to get current - what's
the thought Ematic withdrawal it's a
line of credit that she she went to get
cancel the automatic withdrawal okay
cancel the automatic withdrawal so that
it does so it's not controlling you now
you're going to spend this 600 and then
you're going to spend your fifth check
on paper and you're not going to
intentionally spend more and going to
the red ever again gonna stop it that's
how you do it right there hold on I'm
going to send you a copy the Total Money
Makeover book to help you with this bro
you can do this you guys would be so
rich so fast and be able to do so much
not only for yourselves and for your
family but for others
Oh
Oh